okay so i i want mine down come on
wake up right
so i'm working my guard pass i want some
athleticism
as i'm coming around okay
he's working his counter
to make sure i'm i'm capturing all my
posts okay
boom trap here boom
knee and i'm gonna make it to uh that
next shoulder
okay
[Music]
i gotta get to this thing and my hip in
front of his hip
when i get here and then
he's let's have you do your counter nope
nope check you got it
and then i didn't make it because he's
not letting me get it
move yourself on
so i gotta make it to that shoulder
he's trying his thing i'm controlling
boom and you're gonna get this thing
here you see that
oh force force
okay use your other hand wherever you
want it where do you want it
maybe on me huh do you get it okay
so i can uh
just start crushing crushing them right
so
not into him here like this but
over the top of them this way
so you get his wrist and you're gonna go
same thing here
his wrist and you go over the top of him
this way just like your touchy wasa
don't push on this push hard right and
you're gonna go around it you see
and then you push it
so that's our first thing he's here
you can't go here so you go
into a wrist lock wrist lock
by going around them this way and
crushing them
okay it's in your interest to take them
off
as you feel your wrists being locked
against their joint okay
all right let's try
he's got the good one let's make it
shitty
do you see his angle is
too sheer here
he can stop me i can't get the hook so
that's when i go
into the wristlet you guys are getting
the sheared one
okay on the sheared one just go
underneath this
here like that you passed it okay and
see how i'm going around it just they
don't go
don't give him that ledge go underneath
it
let me get there boom
guy has the shitty counter sheer
don't contest it don't turn right
slip under it and then go around
all of them okay
let's go he's doing that hit one
he's he's stopping me with his hips so
don't don't let these things go
and i'm just holding i'm just holding so
try to sit up
try to sit down you see that's what i'm
doing my elbows are in tight
okay out
there's the hip pocket okay
first secure that arm all right
and then start working to complete the
stance so i have this
check here emerald work
boom here when i do this stance don't
lean back
lean in and get your weight to tap when
you want
my weight is off i don't put the weight
on the on the ground my hips not on the
ground
okay but i'm not leaning so far over
here and he's gonna turn you
so just going around that resistance
this resistance right here don't force
it pop it
boom in
secure pop trap
then fulfill the stance
okay
he gets it late it's late do you see
it's late i still don't want to force it
i'm going to do the other
uh same wrist lock here you see
so i'm going gonna turn over it it's
right there
boom you're gonna get it okay
if it's early you've got a good post on
here
that's when you pop it slide up
if it's late you're gonna attack the
wrist again
this way okay
okay
okay so now he now he gets the sheer
angle
and coming around it's there okay i
don't want to
force force it okay
you it's already popped so you can't pop
it
and i can't go over and attack the wrist
okay so i push it
here i'm still holding it
and i put my knee on the outside my foot
on the inside
and i have weight my weight is on it i
waited on it
okay so i got here
sheer angle you don't want to force that
thing
it's just a very easy right here
here
okay